[Musique]
guillaume qui compte bon jour en jour
véronique merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation tv fil pour ce pour ce vip
nous allons parler de beaucoup de choses
avec vous et historien et vous êtes
auteur et parfois commissaire
d'exposition voilà donc on va commencer
par le début à savoir un des premiers
livres que vous avez écrit qu'ils
étaient dites moi quel était ce pays or
ce livre s'intitule la route des rois de
france il était donc édité par larousse
et s'intéressait à la fois aux rois et
empereurs qui ont régné sur la france
ainsi qu'un cas la royauté c'est à dire
les grands moments qui structurent la
vie des rois sacre funérailles mariage
guerre etc et puis d'accord pardon et
ses livres et sertic un ce livre est
sorti en 2008 avec sur la couverture la
couronne de sacre de louis 15 ou non les
bijoux
véritable à l'origine ont été remplacés
par des pierres semi-précieuses donc ce
côté un peu kitsch qui donne à cette
couronne une certaine actualité et puis
il ya eu l'année suivante aux éditions
du chêne un petit livre sur les rois de
france où il s'agissait de présenter
tous les rois qui se sont succédé sur le
trône en 1506 donc en courte notice à
l'école donc vous avez démarré eric j'ai
démarré avec les premiers mérovingiens
n'est mérovée qui est l'ancêtre
légendaire et fondateur de la dynastie
mérovingienne et 15 jusqu'à napoléon iii
dernier souverain empereur à avoir régné
sur la france d'accord ça c'est un petit
livre bien bien qu'on s'y
quelle que soit la durée du règne
quelles que soient ses grands mais non
de la connaissance qu'on a aujourd'hui
s'ouvre à la même médecine donc pour
louis xiv il faut faire des choix
drastiques si pour telle ou telle
mérovingiens sur lequel on sait très peu
de choses eh bien il faut puiser du côté
de la légende ou de la peinture 19e pour
aborder l'histoire raconte exactement
d'accord très bien ensuite vous avez
aussi participer à certaines expositions
contemporaines oui et là je suis aussi
un trait de me tromper parce qu'en fait
avant la pause sur les expositions vous
avez aussi
commis un livre qui s'appelle
invitations privées à versailles ce qui
permet de voir des endroits complètement
inédit et caché au grand public oui j'ai
écrit les textes de ce livre qui a été
édité par flammarion et pour ce travail
flammarion a réalisé une nouvelle
campagne de photos et a obtenu l'accès à
des lieux rares comme ce qu'on appelle
la garde-robe de 2016 eh ben c'est le
lieu dans lequel était à ranger les
vêtements du roi et de swing exactement
et ce lieu était décorée avec des
boiseries d'une très grande qualité et
qui sont aujourd'hui considérés comme
des chefs-d'oeuvre de l'artisanat de
l'époque vous avez également la salle de
bain de marie antoinette qui elle aussi
est décoré par de magnifiques
magnifiques boiseries puis évidemment
vous avez des lieux très importants qui
sont le grand trianon et le petit
trianon dans lequel marie antoinette
aimait à se retirer pour s'éloigner de
la pesanteur de l'étiquette de la crau
de france eq alors pourquoi est-ce que
c'est ces lieux sont cachés au public
c'est à dire que si on prend la gare
d'europe de 2016 sont des lieux exigus
donc il est difficile
de les inclure dans la circuit classique
de la visite où vous avez quand même un
flux important de visiteurs qui passent
et qui risquerait d'abîmer ces lieux qui
ont été récemment récemment restaurée
d'accord idem pour la salle de bain
exactement d'accord et elle a dans les
jardins dans le parc est ce que vous
nous fait découvrir les impacts dans le
parc vous avez plusieurs choses vous
avez déjà
toute une partie des sculptures qui ont
été conservés des sculptures qui ont été
soit achetée par le roi soit commandée
par les différents souverains pour
décorer et aider tel endroit que vous
avez ce qu'on appelle des bosquette
c'est à dire que vous avez les endroits
c'est en vous avez de la végétation est
au coeur de cette végétation vous avez
vous avez des espaces prévus pour le
délassement pour la fête avec à nouveau
des sculptures etc et puis vous avez ces
superbes perspectives qui conduisent de
bassan bassin jusqu'au jusqu'au grand
canal d'accord donc tout ça est visible
dans ce magnifique versailles invitation
prévu voilà après alors on passe à une
exposition au lien show terrain que j'ai
eu la chance d'organiser au côté de jean
jacques aillagon qui était une
exposition qui nous avait été commandée
par la région nord pas de calais et la
communauté urbaine de dunkerque en 2013
année où la ville de dunkerque avait été
élue capitale pour la culture de la
région un nord pas de calais et dans
cette exposition il s'agissait de
confronter des oeuvres d'art
plus ancien avec des oeuvres d'art
contemporain comment des oeuvres issues
de la collection pinault d'accord très
bien et une deuxième expo de l'addition
on reconnaît le homard dodgers encore
une cape est exposé jean jacques
aillagon à versailles et là encore une
exposition
réalisée aux côtés de jean jacques
aillagon pour la ville de dinard et sur
le thème de la nourriture dans dans
l'art contemporain avec entre autres les
oeuvres de kunz mais aussi la thématique
du renouvellement d'argent anciens qui
est celui de la nature morte voir
comment les artistes contemporains à 300
par et renouvelle la nature morte existe
encore été renouvelée de façon
étonnante et très intéressante j'imagine
très bien alors là on va pouvoir revenir
à notre mouton principales n'ont
toujours pas toujours pas alors avant de
d'arriver à ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui très rapidement de livres
un livre sur écrivains et artistes face
à la grande guerre auxquels j'ai
participé avec des amis également
historien de l'art et puis cette
anthologie de poèmes de poilus que j'ai
dirigés pour le seuil et dont une des
originalités et cala rassemble des
poèmes écrits pas uniquement par des
combattants français mais des
combattants de toutes les nationalités
et de tous les bords dont vous avez
aussi bien des poètes allemand anglais
français russe italien autrichien et
c'est donc pour montrer comment la
guerre est perçu à travers la poésie et
souvent on se rend compte que la poésie
est une force d'expression qui permet de
toucher au plus juste des horreurs de la
guerre de façon plus efficace que la
prose d'accord ça c'était par rapport
aux centenaires j'étais évidemment au
centenaire de la déclaration de la
grande guerre en 2014 très bien alors
maintenant est bien monté riches ça vous
en faites des jeux cet épuisant alors
maintenant on va pouvoir parler de ce
fameux livre là que je tiens que je
montre l'histoire de france expliqué par
la peinture noire elle a édité c'est
toujours chez large au jour casser la
croissance qui vient de paraître et pour
lequel j'ai retenu 50 événements ou
épisode de l'histoire de france expliqué
par la peinture et dans certains cas je
présente en contrepoint d'une oeuvre
principale une autre oeuvre représentant
le maine le même événement avec une
autre vision dans ce quart exactement là
encore le disions alors donc comme il
existe des peintres de cours apparemment
il existait des peintres d'histoire oui
la peinture d'histoire un vrai métier
exactement qu'il tenait avant vous
m'avez disais
non je vais vous dire que avant les
journalistes en effet et surtout pendant
très longtemps la peinture d'histoire
est considéré comme le premier genre
c'est à dire que delacroix se considère
d'abord comme un peintre d'histoire
d'accord ok et alors quel est leur rôle
à ses peintres ce sont des oeuvres qui
sont commandités par les souverains de
plusieurs que d'ailleurs sont souvent
des oeuvres qui sont commandés par les
puissants à commencer par les rois et
des oeuvres qui représente soit des
événements passés de l'histoire
continuer l'histoire de france soit des
événements
contentera ouais voilà d'accord et donc
on l'a on leur donne la ligne directrice
on leur donne l'idéologie à faire
transparaître mais ça dépend des cas de
figure vous pouvez avoir un cahier des
charges extrêmement ouvert ou au
contraire un cahier des charges très
précis où la position la situation des
différents personnages et précisé ainsi
que l'atmosphère générale visant si
c'est une victoire trop chèrement
acquise en nombre de vies humaines mais
visant par exemple à atténuer
les massacres ou le côté sanguinolent
visant également à à magnifier la la
figure du souverain qui a participé à
l'événement représenté d'accord et du
coup c'est une forme de propagande quoi
c'est vraiment pour influencer l'opinion
et etc si la crasse que s'ouvre a envie
de laisser tout à faire voilà la danse
dans un récit historique construit et
qui est conçu comme un moyen de
communication pour le pouvoir
d'accord donc là on va on va regarder
sur notre écran les cinq oeuvres qui
sont on a sélectionné dans sa dans ce
livre
donc nous avons après donc là vous avez
une première oeuvre qui est une
enluminure donc c'est la peinture de
petits formats à telle qu'elle est
pratiquée au moyen-âge et 7 ans lumine
sûrs qui date du 14ème siècle représente
le baptême de clovis alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce manuscrit a
appartenu au roi de france qui est
charles 5 ce qui signifie que les scènes
représentées répondent à une attention
politique et sur cette scène du baptême
de clovis
on aperçoit dans le coin supérieur droit
une colombe qui descend du ciel et cette
colombe c'est l'intervention divine qui
apporte une remise parfaite excusez moi
je vous coupe mais c'est bourré symbole
et c'est pour ça que ce qui est très
intéressant c'est la façon dont vous
vous montrez les tableaux avec une sorte
de mosaïque en reprenant et en étant le
focus sur isolant des détails pour elle
a expliqué aux décors aux lecteurs que
là il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
valeur et que je m'efforce de 92 la
signification vous remplacez le guide en
fait c'est exactement voilà alors après
le deuxième tableau on va
malheureusement aller alors là vous avez
un très beau tableau d'ingres qui
représente jeanne d'arc lors du sacre de
charles vii et vous le voyez ce qui est
très intéressant dans le choix opéré par
un gang c'est que le roi qui est sacré
chars le 7 n'apparaît pas sur le tableau
donc ce qui l'intéresse dingue mais
c'est la figure de jeanne d'arc grâce à
qui charles vii a pu être sacrés
d'accord alors ensuite on va pouvoir
regarder l'autre celui-là il est en
pleine actualité
voilà donc ils répondent à cette
passionnante exposition qui se tient au
musée lambinet de versailles consacré je
crois
la rémission est là vous avez ce un des
tableaux les plus connues du peintre
david conçu comme un hommage à mara qui
a été assassiné dans sa baignoire par
charlotte corday et le choix que fait
david est aussi riche de signification
puisque david représente marat assassiné
donc mara après avoir été assassinées
par charlotte corday ce qui permet à
david d'évacuer la figure de charlotte
corday au profit du seul mara qui est
représenté à la fois comme un martyr et
presque comme un christ de douleurs de
la révolution française donc là encore
on est dans un récit construit et un
résident de propagande voilà
complètement subjectif il est magnifié
etc après voilà ce grandiose car alors
nous passons la révolution le premier le
premier empire nous sommes sous la
restauration un nouveau roi vient de
monter sur le trône il s'agit de charles
10 qui décide de renouer avec les vieux
rituel de la royauté d'avant la
révolution a commencé par le sacre du
roi charles vi a été sacré à reims et là
selon la l'ancienne tradition des rois
de france il rentre à paris et là est
organisée une entrée royale en son
honneur et il se trouve que étant donné
que la population française des années
1820 n'était pas celle d'avant la
révolution l'entousiasme des parisiens a
été nettement moins fervents que ce que
représente ce tableau du bar on rit
jaune j'étais un petit fils en a rajouté
un petit peu dire voilà des cas bon ben
écoutez si on termine avec ce trailer
tableau de delacroix qui s'intitule la
liberté guidant le peuple qui a été
terminée en 1831 et qui est en réalité
une représentation de la révolution de
1830 qui a lieu en france et qui marque
le passage des bourbons restaurer à la
monarchie de juillet
génial merci merci à vous alors on vous
retrouve au salon histoire de lire à
versailles vous êtes là le samedi le
dimanche le samedi 26 novembre le samedi
14h à 18h30 très bien on viendra vous
voir gouverneur a acheté ce magnifique
quel de noël parce que c'est juste très
beau très très intéressant et flamboyant
voilà je vous remercie c'est moi
[Musique]